sixty-six years ago this month DW
Griffith's Birth of a Nation opened and
created a sensation that's never been
duplicated the star of that landmark
film made her first movie in 1912 she
has continued on an unprecedented career
she was honored by this Academy in 1971
and she returns tonight to announce the
Best Picture this glowing lady is proof
that not only is film forever but so is
the enduring beauty and artistry of Miss
Lillian Gish
thank you such a small to words for so
much but thank you
the birth of the nation marked the birth
of the power of film it played to three
times the population of America in the
year since we have witnessed and
participated in films continued vitality
as represented by the five films
nominated as the best of this year they
are Coal Miner's Daughter a biography of
the ritalin and her rise from obscurity
to fame a Bernard Schwartz Universal
Pictures production Universal Bernard
Schwartz producer the Elephant Man the
story of one of history's most
unfortunate men a Brooks field films
limited production paramount Jonathan
Sanger producer
ordinary people a film about the lack of
communication that nearly destroys a
family a Wildwood enterprises production
paramount Ronald L Warren producer
Raging Bull The Odyssey of a fighters
victories in the ring and his losses in
life a Robert shot off urban wit Glen
production United Artists Robert short
off and Irwin Winkler produces
yes the classic tale of a young woman's
pride and her passionate determination
to defend it a wren Barilla production
Columbia clog berry produces Timothy
gorilla co-producer and this is the time
I like ordinary people
on behalf of wildwood enterprises and
Paramount Pictures I would like to thank
the members of the Academy for this
award from the beginning of production
until the release distribution of the
picture there was a special pride shared
by all in the making of ordinary people
the author judith guest screenwriter
Alvin Sargent editor Jeff canoe an
excellent cast Donald Mary Tim Judd and
a dedicated hard-working crew to these
deserving people we owe our sincere
thanks as far back as four and a half
years ago when Robert Redford acquired
the novel he strongly believed that this
could be a very special film this belief
along with his sensitive direction was
the inspiration behind the project I
want to thank Bob for giving me the
opportunity to produce this picture and
I want to say he must come up here and
share this with me Bob
along
thank you very much
this is Hector speaking
Thursday night Levites after imposter
was infiltrated the 12th precinct on
Barney Miller and then Lois may not
survive when Tony finds out he's been
double-crossed on taxi followed by 2020
when Geraldo Rivera examines the
devastating conflict in the Middle East
the unholy war on 20/20 Thursday later
tonight
ABC News Nightline reports on how easy
it is to buy a gun